welcome to episode 91 something really
weird is happening what what the hell
there has anybody ever had this like
seriously I've had this from this this
problem like for the last couple weeks I
sometimes hear myself through my own ear
I don't want to hear yourself especially
not you me you don't want to hear my
voice come on and it's just weird but
and then no I'm not looking for I self
through my headset in any case this
episode speech is the regular sort of
stuff well not really now to to major
sort of developments that are going on
in this episode that is not fixing the
log flume that's - something that I
really quickly had to do to actually
make it functional there were many
people in the stream who were asking for
a POV and you know I'm always open for
that stuff the only problem was it
wasn't even functional I did figure out
why it didn't work for some reason it
only works when it's the track in the
water like when it's the track in the
water it's gonna slow down when it hits
the water is gonna do the splashing
sound and it's gonna do some fun stuff
but as soon as it enters the water in
that strike bed that sort of log flume
looking thing it doesn't work and it
doesn't slow down and it just speeds
through the what's in like friction
doesn't exist so that actually fixed it
so that was pretty nice I mean it's a
bit weird now I have to get the tracks
underneath it but then again there's a
there's still a couple of problems to
fix it's still in its babyface so
there's some problems with that as well
there is over here basically the first
thing that's how it's doing this episode
I don't even think I really said what
two major developments that were in this
episode so let me just quickly explain
that so you so you know I suppose the
first thing is to add a train station
over here which I know it doesn't make
any sense
however the the idea behind it is that's
what it looks good
it's one thing and it could have been a
abandoned train station one that had
that was formerly used in the park but
is now abandoned because it doesn't
really connect to anything anymore
or one that is religious though as a
decoration in my case for the in-game
thing it's really just a decoration I
didn't want to have a cliff face over
here for the same reason that I did want
to get those small buildings on the rock
as I have explained in the I think it's
episode 89 since I didn't want to have
just empty rocks all
the place and get a still rocky looking
area over here so this station is over
here to prevent bats get some more
building action in here and I did sort
of feel like building and it's a
building like this
I suppose it's nothing special really
and I'm still not too sure about how it
came out even when I was building it and
there were loads of rebuilding the
towers and figuring out what sort of
roof I really wanted to have and I made
a clock for it and then the render
distance was way too small so that
didn't work and there was also set which
I thought had a good clock in it but I
couldn't find the set so problems all
over that's but in the end I think it
works out for simple building just two
wings with a small tower in the middle
really the standard sort of train
station but without the paths on the
side of course without those very
trained looking ironworks or things like
that but even without that I think it
works out alright as a simple decoration
on the side of this thing the second
major developments in this video by the
way is going to be some planning on
areas what you'll find the first area
that I'm going to do after this it's
going to be the touch area and I already
wanted to start while I was doing this
basically since I felt like it
that's the only reason really but I did
have to get some planning in for the
areas around that's why I wanted to get
the the Austrian area the German area
and the English area which the Dutch
area is going to be surrounded by so
we'll see how how that is going to work
out in the end the only two other areas
that I still want to plan around that is
the Baltic / Russian area with maybe a
bit of both not sure yet if I really
want to do the Russian theme and of
course the Romanian area though that
might also change do something slightly
different there were some people who
suggested to try a Hungarian area at the
Romania's place instead I just feel like
Romania would be the best fits and then
I would go for the more Transylvanian
looking Romania since it would provide a
good transition from the yeah you
basically got a really good transition
honestly we go from we go from the mock
tutor and England to the tutor in
Germany to the Alpine sort of houses
that really transition from the German
of wood houses to the more Austrian ones
and then from that we go into the
and to the Romanian theme and then after
that it's going to be a really harsh
transition to the Japanese theme somehow
but actually Russian could play a small
role in that that's basically what I was
hoping to get some Russian would action
since I have actually looks and I've
also been forced to look at some wood
Russian houses and I do think that there
is some that there is some potential to
use that as a transition to go from the
the wood of the Romanian area to the
wooden houses that you would have in the
Japanese area from which once again you
go to the Korean / Chinese area which
has a lot more stone in it than Japanese
but I'm holy [ __ ] I'm getting much more
ahead of myself than usual it's a couple
of episodes many episodes actually the
server here is not a major development
by the way just a small sundial and I
felt like working on this thing this
area is still looking a tiny bit empty
and yes you can you can probably say
that I have a fear of the emptiness
which is which probably appears
throughout whatever I ever built in
rollercoaster kanthri but then again it
just happens I don't wanna leave too
many empty spots that being said I do
want to I do have to sort of leave it in
the Main Street area which is why not
it's not going to look too interesting
since that area is gonna have to
actually be able to take on many guests
so that's also one thing your parks look
so much different when they're actually
filled with guests just having those
guests walk around and it's usually only
in the first area of your park since
guest a I and roller coaster can three
or I am very sorry I should call them
peeps I was one of the most stupid
things every luck seriously roller
coaster can three peeps I mean this is
not a rap group come on and break
dancing Panda
they were trying to be cool and it was
so cringy but I'm getting that is very
off topic basically you know there's
always the problem that the guests are
scattered or orange scattered throughout
your park but are all just cluttered
around your entrance I really because
terrible AI and I don't think I can
really do much about that but I still
want to get as many guests as I can in
as many of the areas in the park as I
can since like I said it does kind of
help to make your park look that tiny
bit more alive definitely without guests
it just ends up looking quite still and
boring and sure it still has
the aesthetic well it still has the
aesthetic properties that I'm looking
for of course but it doesn't have as
much of an atmosphere as you can have
when you actually have guests in your
Park now I think at this point the train
is actually almost finished almost there
just a tiny bit of foliage work over
there I sometimes you really can notice
that I'm running out of ideas of what I
should work on not necessarily ideas of
what I should build but just on what I
should work on sometimes you just
finished something and have no idea what
to move on with it so that was just a
bit of foliage work over here but I must
add this is really just filling and this
is really just to make this area look
that tiny bit more finished and just so
that the park as a whole I finished I
find it I just find it motivational for
myself just how the park looked like
it's actually turning out into a real
theme park rather than the dead middle
of a grassy valley that it really is in
what a Costa country so that's why I
kind of wanted to get that in and after
that we're moving on to the planning
which can be great and yeah the foliage
over here really is a placeholder by the
way there are many gaps don't have to
really comment about the lack of foliage
over here or my lack of even doing it
right I really couldn't carry it too
much at that point I would like let's
get some simple foliage over here make
it look good from a distance but soon as
you zoom it it looks like [ __ ] so I'm
gonna get those details in later and
I'll spam the beach fans cross set later
- that's all gonna happen at some point
in the future not exactly sure what
point in the future but the hell all
definitely happen since it is blatantly
clear that all that foliage over there
is unfinished but I just I just sort of
wanted to move on to the planning of the
areas since nuts both very important and
something that I needed to be able to
move on there's still a couple things in
the Spanish area that are unfinished but
those are the that those are all the
things that I at some point didn't feel
like doing or a said we'll try that
later and at the points and at the point
as I was recording this I still feel
didn't feel like doing them so um it
didn't happen in the end just was like
now I'm gonna quite do that I'll do some
basic planning instead that being said
by the way I do still need more to this
log flume
it really I really have the idea that
it's just rocks with trees at the
moments and yeah there is of course the
occasional building and honestly log
flumes in real life aren't that's well
themed but I still want to get more
random stuff in here it's gonna be
really hard since there is so much water
especially compared to other log flumes
which are usually a very small canal
where the log flume is going through if
it is a very heavily themed log flume
where you have much scenery around it
for example what's that thing called
again
choppers at phantasialand does have that
very small canal and also goes pretty
damn high and it has smelly dog ride
elements and a lot of scenery around it
but that was something that was very
hard for me to do over here since it was
all at the same height and I couldn't
elevate it in a way that choppers did
since I did have to make it much smaller
and then that ride and I couldn't stack
it because there I do need real water
for those log flume it actually works
and that's that's also that over there
is the Train that I talked about I think
at the end of last episode and in case
anybody is going to ask in the future I
do foresee that happening that is dust
mutters train city you can find it if
you google those mutts of strange CT you
do have to get the invisible station set
for that as well but that is included in
the download link I'm pretty sure and
that should work out it's a really
amazing city I can definitely recommend
it it does have a bit of a sketchy
texture I have actually heard some
people who prefer the in-game train but
then again I do kind of like how it has
the gravel underneath it rather than
either the grass or the standard track
mats that everybody has used since 2010
and of course there's the extra curves
and more gentle slopes but in any case I
at this point started working on the
touch area which not too much happened
in that area at this point really just
some basic planning and seeing if I
could build a building I have no idea
but the first Dutch dreams are probably
the first Dutch time lapses are not
going to be too good I was just being
funny but not actually doing too much
stuff in the streams for that but still
it did somewhat work outs and honestly
looking back there is a lot that still
needed to be do what oh my god
oh my god I'm very sorry for that that
is the worst thing I've ever seen
said that's that's like and that they
don't think it'd be like it is but it do
it's that sort of thing I need to need
to not not remember that but people
won't probably probably span that
summits I've created the new meme in any
case it's time to move on I don't to
create memes it's terrible and not
better not happen what I was trying to
say is that that was a lot that still
needed to be done for the Dutch area
since there's a couple problems well
there's actually one big problem it's
called custom scenery as much as we all
like it there are no Dutch sets there is
CTR since colonial sets but that is what
it says it is a colonial set is not
meant to recreate things like Amsterdam
with and there is the efteling set but
then again that is the EFT language does
have their own distinct style and there
are many things that I still like all
right let's go small this actually did
make a list of things that I needed to
make custom seen you before
haven't made it yet because that's the
end that's the less fun part of the
entire process but over there in the
middle of the canal where the the
vertical part over there keeps going
that also crosses that bridge from the
Spanish area to the Dutch area I want to
have a suspension bridge a very typical
Dutch suspension bridge I don't know if
anybody knows about it but Duchess will
probably recognize will probably know
what I'm talking about those those that
they're basically vertical pillars which
have horizontal beams on it and if they
basically suspend one half of the bridge
and I think they're made of wood
sometimes but I'm not sure yeah these
smaller ones I think are but they're
nicely colored and there they are pretty
nice thing to see and as soon as you
place one bridge in anywhere it's gonna
look pretty damn Dutch there is of
course also the more Dutch building
things for example I really need to get
some Amsterdam cables that's the most
important thing the cables that's pretty
much with Amsterdam focuses on also
needed to get some windows that I can
actually use since Amsterdam has really
simple windows with white borders around
them and very similar actually I started
doing some research in Amsterdam itself
see what it looks like and many windows
over there are exactly the same thing
which was very very surprising I found
but yeah windows were also something
that I need to get and there is what
else was there that was something else I
know that there was some
else I just forgot it at some point I
thought that I needed new path colors
but turned out that pets actually had
some great particles which Disney aka
Quinn showed me so that was awesome and
thank you for that once again there was
one other thing though yeah the smaller
houses I want to get those smaller
wooden / blue wooden houses that's not
just wooden / blue those green / blue
wooden houses that you'd see in these
smaller towns in the Netherlands that's
also something that I want to get in
that being said I don't want to make it
too realistic and I don't wanna make it
too beautiful I know that sounds really
weird but I don't make it seem out of
place Lee realistic compared to the
other areas and I do aim to make it all
very realistic but sometimes you do need
to consider that it's just a theme park
and to deviate tiny bits from what is
completely realistic I think should be
alright especially if it's in favor of
what it's going to look like so yeah if
any points I might make something look
very good but unrealistic and not very
much like its real-life counterparts
that is why it's going to happen so I'm
not gonna exactly be recreating any
building so people were requesting if I
could recreate some buildings
I don't exactly want to do that I do
want to still get a bit of a my own
thing but of course these facades on
this side of the river are going to be
the amsterdam facades and the train
station which is going to be right next
to it it is going to be inspired by the
train station in the hog and in
Amsterdam I also totally meant to say
The Hague why did that even come from so
yeah I'm going to aim for a similar
style as how the buildings are in the
respective countries but it's not gonna
be exactly the same and over here I was
really just messing with the the wall
pieces since that's also something that
I when it's getting different brick
textures since facades and Amsterdam are
really disappointing I'm gonna have to
say this as a whole Amsterdam is really
beautiful and the canals are absolutely
amazing and the city as a whole is its
beautiful site but looking at the
building's individually it's really
nothing there are barely any details on
it they don't have any interesting
shapes whatsoever they're just straight
buildings made out of different sorts of
bricks with simple windows and the only
real thing that makes them stand out is
steve is the gables that's the only
thing that the poor amsterdam people
could even afford him so that's what
it's gonna be like they were also very
straight for science I can't really mess
too much with different positions of the
buildings on one facade since all the
buildings in one streets essentially
stick out and like just as much as each
other though there's no building
sticking out more than another one
that's no galleries like who like you
would have in Mediterranean countries
and that's a bit of shame and then I
guess I see that I do have to wrap it up
at this point also that white a little
corners thing that I built over that
looks like a plate poop it could be them
gonna be removed later on but yeah I do
have to M be video I do have to end the
video over here so thank you for
watching and I'll see you later
also I'm currently in London so I'm
gonna have a hard time responding to
anything which also goes through episode
90 so this is also pre uploaded and
scheduled for release and so that's why
I am stop this why I'm pretty dead but
I'll be I'll be back the 10th of August
so don't worry about it